[Music]
roof
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
well
this should take too long
with psychic
and today
is my first day on the job get ready
did you forget everything i taught you
about levitation rasputin
i'm not supposed to check out equipment
to interns
you did
what
can we just no
quit picking on the new kid we were all
new once in case you forgot i've got
eyes on the target
and i've got eyes on me
all i see is another unruly peasant
oh boys
it wouldn't be the first time the
psychonauts underestimated molecular
power
fire
leave it to me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes i wonder what this city looked
like before all this
probably like many others
people had their ambitions
plans lives
now it's all gone
the virus started it
but it was the people who made the world
the way it is
this city
villadore
they tell me they had a vision
they had hope
but soon
one vision
broke into many different ones
instead of fighting together
people stood against each
war other out
was it a little bird
lit a broken leg
hope died
now the city is falling
each time we strike down an enemy we
absorb their strength
but i can't let that happen
at least
not yet
[Applause]
i need the secrets this city holds oh
[ __ ] hey
still some rats here
i have to pick a side the bizarre needs
good people
you're doing great so far
[Music]
i have to make a difference
let's check and see
they say that great change is a series
of small gestures
[Music]
how about this series
is all hope really gone
we'll see about that
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
the holy detonation is
life
deep within cheyenne mountain we've
changed
devolved into the mutations you see
before you
set on a righteous path
the holy detonation's life-giving glow
should be shared with everyone
morning may the light of the holy
detonation purify
join us
rangers
so when i think about cloud and when i
think about gaming those two things
together to me really show you the
future where you can pick up something
and you can play it anywhere and you
could do it quickly
[Music]
cloud game looks phenomenal that's
pretty great i mean this is that's
pretty awesome this actually looks so
good
games are large and you want to keep the
ones that you know you love on your hard
drive xbox cloud gaming is about being
able to discover the new ones right away
it's super exciting that for our game
pass ultimate members they will get to
experience xbox cloud gaming on whatever
console they have cloud gaming is really
about looking at how people play
differently i know me in particular
sometimes i just have 20 minutes
it should be as easy as finding the game
that you look for on your console and
just jumping right in we're targeting
1080p at 60 frames per second what's
crazy about this is like the latency
this is the kind of stuff you need with
cloud gaming oh 60 frames that's
actually very smooth
the process itself to get into cloud
gaming feels like you're playing a
console right you go you find the game
you want you press play it's so easy
nowadays you can pick up any device and
pretty much play any xbox game on game
pass
[Music]
if my friends have titles that i don't
have yet i can just wait for them to
send me an invite and it makes content
just so much more accessible
i really love the flexibility it's
awesome
everything that xbox is doing right now
is just getting rid of the limits of
having to be on a specific platform or a
specific console play on pc and mobile
and now on gen 8 yeah gen 8 consoles can
play gen 9 content isn't that so cool
with cloud gaming we have the ability
because you are connecting to consoles
that are in our data centers to allow
the gen 8 customers the xbox one
customers to play games that their
hardware wouldn't have been able to play
without it there's so much opportunity
when it comes to thinking about how we
can make content more readily available
and let people play where they want to
sign me up i'm ready for cloud gaming
right now let's do it when's the release
date when does it release
[Music]
i don't like this weather
i'm pretty sure the ship's insurance
won't cover alien storm damage
you have to be careful out there
the gunk's eating everything here
this planet is literally a paradise when
the gunk's gone
[Music]
eggs
oh please
you